Wow you four decorated I don't like it
[Applause]
[Music]
alright folks it's time for a Doctor Who
list these are always fun and this one
is brought to you by my own patreon and
I mentioned that because this was a
topic voted on and helped decide it by
my patreon supporters at any tier of
support you do get to help vote on
topics and help me decide which things
to tackle next
when I have a few ideas going around
also you get to see the dockets for what
is cut in the upcoming months and even
at fairly inexpensive tiers you get
things like access to the discord your
name and the credits and plus there's
other stuff beyond that I'm done
plugging myself and so let's move things
along so this time I am going to be
ranking my own personal top two but well
bottom to top that's the order I'm doing
them in TARDIS interiors because TARDIS
has been redesigned a lot and some of
them have been great some of them not so
much now strictly speaking this is not
every single variant of the TARDIS
interiors cuz sometimes there are things
that were like really minor tweaks like
the overall and also when I say TARDIS
interior I'm talking about the control
room because only a couple of different
points in the show have they actually
showed as much of the TARDIS outside of
the control room and that's always the
main centerpiece so that's really what
I'm gonna be talking about here so like
I said that there have been times where
like very little changes but they tweak
the like the panels on the console like
not dealing with those kind of bearings
these were the ones that I could look at
and go that is distinctly different from
the other one so by that rationale I
have 14 that I need to rank because I I
do get to include classic who in this
particular list so let's start at the
bottom work our way up number
14 what I think of as the flat wall
TARDIS this was I believe this was the
initial interior TARDIS design for the
Fourth Doctor and they just they just
took the depth out of the wall and they
the I I've seen them called various
things but like the round things those
used to be way more distinct either
because they were slightly recessed back
or because they were a different shade
of some kind of colors sometimes white
or whatever then the rest of the wall
here it's just like a slight circular
indentation in a uniformly colored wall
and it's boring it flattens the room in
a lot of ways and it's one of the the
few that I distinctly don't like because
much like when I do something like rank
the doctors only a handful of the ones
at the very bottom row Orleans I
actually don't enjoy and then it's just
a matter of ranging you know how much I
do or don't like them so that one
occupies the bottom spot moving up from
that one we have what I can only think
of as the salad bowl walls so this was
during the Third Doctor's tenure and
yeah I mean they're very obviously very
big plastic salad bowls and normally I
try not to harp too hard on you know the
wonky production design but like this is
a this was a step back from what it had
already been up to that point they look
weird they look cheap it does it just
doesn't work Casso looks fine but the
walls just no and those are really the
only two that I flat out don't like and
now we're just getting to ones that yeah
I'm just ranking the order in which I
like them so number twelve we have the
the secondary TARDIS console room
otherwise known as the wood TARDIS
interior so this appeared during the
fourth doctor's era I in one story I
forget which one specifically now
somebody will mention in the comments
cuz somebody always does whenever I miss
a detail but it's
it's an interesting variant but I'm
really glad that this never became the
standard interior designed for the
TARDIS it's it's cute for a one-off but
otherwise I'm like knit we didn't need
to keep saying that
so moving up one spot to number 11 feet
it fittingly enough the eleventh
Doctor's TARDIS so this is the yellow
crystal room now I'll put an asterisk on
this one because I feel like I don't
actually have a proper sense of it it's
one of the things that I that kind of
bugged me about series 11 I didn't feel
like we spent a lot of time in the
TARDIS it didn't feel like a base of
operations it didn't feel like the place
where they kept coming back to it just
felt like an occasional spot that we
would see them exchange but it's a
dialogue in I didn't really get a strong
sense of it and maybe if we spend more
time in in future series with that
design maybe I will warm to it more but
for right now this is where it sits and
there's a lot that I like about this
design I find it interesting I like the
way in which sort of the crystalline
forms and the color of them kind of
mimic the sonic screwdriver I actually
kind of like that it's a little overly
dark and one of the things that bugs me
about a fair number of the modern era
Doctor Who and TARDIS interiors is they
tend to flood with like a single color
of white which don't really care for all
that much and that's very much the case
here it's super yellow it's a little
claustrophobic because of the way that
the arch is kind of bend in so they're
not just up there like encroaching in so
it's not awful but I don't love it
number 10 speaking of too much of one
color the this is the second TARDIS
interior for the eleventh Doctor
introduced in the episode the Snowman
and I just think of it as oh so very
green it like there's some cool stuff in
here I do kind of like how it's got the
whole spinning you know almost sort of
settings or cogs and almost
up at the top that the the you know the
bit in the middle goes up and down into
that's kind of cooled the walkways are
neat but it's it's also too dark and is
relying way too much on just the color
green it makes it visually uninteresting
despite a rather interesting design so
if they just shot it differently I will
probably like it better for number nine
we go to the fifth doctor's era and this
was I believe the like the last major
update to the interior of the TARDIS
during the classic era and it held all
through six and sevens tenure so this
had a redesign on the columns and also
read a noticeable redesign on the
console which was now with way more
keyboards fewer levers fewer buttons
tons of keyboards and it's it's fine you
know it's a tweaking of the classic
design but I find the keyboards to be
kind of dull I like I like what I can
look at the console and see a bunch of
things like wonder what that does wonder
what that is what does that do you show
me a keyboard I'm like well I know what
that does and you know you can tell me
all you want about oh but it's this kind
of function I'm like yeah but it's
keyboard I know what a keyboard is and
it kind of it kind of makes it slightly
less interesting and also the the style
and the columns I don't like as much as
the style of columns we'll see on a
version of the Tarsus higher up so let's
keep moving which brings us to now in
color the first artists interior for the
third doctor and it's it's good I mean
that's kind of it this one Falls almost
precisely in the middle and it's just
that I really have nothing to complain
about but just I think that really makes
me go oh that's a great touch right
there it's just it's good and now what's
probably gonna be a bit of a
controversial choice for not having it
up higher but the choral so this was the
TARDIS interior for the entirety of the
9th and 10th doctor series 1 through
series pool actually series 1 through
the Tennant specials so
for a lot of people they have a lot of
nostalgia for this one and I do too
this was the TARDIS that was being used
when I first fell in love with the show
and it avoided being shot too dark most
of the time if it was shot um dark there
was usually a story reason for it to be
doing that on despite the fact that
there's kind of a lot of orange warm
colors going on they would shake up the
lighting now and then occasionally
they'd Papa you know bit of green in
there with a with a lighting setup for
things like that so it kept it visually
more interesting than sort of uniforming
the color palette but I don't know this
maybe it's maybe it's almost because I
saw it for too long that I just kind of
was tired of it by the end and as it's
one of those things that honestly a bit
like David tennis performance as the
doctor as I came to understand the width
and breadth of Doctor Who stuff in
general better I came to like it less
not because it's not good but because I
realized there's other Doctor Who stuff
that I like more so that's kind of where
this one ends up number six the original
so the the interior and the console room
for the first and second doctor's the
black and white console and like it's
just classic the thing is as much as I'm
gonna talk about the various redesigns
of the console room over the years not a
lot changed throughout the entire
classic era of Doctor Who from this
original design because it just works
the round things the console has a stark
centerpiece right in the middle of the
whole thing it's just really striking
and it works really well in black and
white they've got enough varying shades
of things that even the fact that it
isn't in color everything is distinct
and draws your eyes to where it needs to
be it's just masterful sci-fi design for
black and white television and it still
holds up okay so we get to number five
and this is the final classic era Doctor
Who TARDIS on the list which means the
classics knobs are going to be mad at me
for
for that fact and the the tenant fans
will be mad at me for ranking the choral
one lower lower is there it can I tick
off everybody with this list let's see
let's keep going
but in any case so this was the fourth
doctor's version where the columns first
initially got introduced so it was a
little bit of a new dynamic kind of
broke up the wall a little bit and also
it restored the Nate the proper nature
of the round things because like I
mentioned in my very bottom of the list
when they kind of flattened out the
walls like that's really uninteresting
this this had them the way they should
have been and they had the columns which
I think were a nice touch and gave it
you know a less uniform look looking
around the TARDIS which I thought was a
nice way to break it up and give it a
little bit more of an distinct feel in
specific areas of the of the room and
the interior and in my opinion it's the
best the interior of the terrace look
during the classic era number four this
is the twelfth doctors TARDIS now in
terms of actual design interior this is
basically the exact same one that the
eleventh Doctor had in his redesign that
I had so much lower so why is this one
higher well a couple of reasons a little
bit more variety in colour because even
though there's still a lot of green
going on lighting wise we get some
orange in there because they change the
light sort of in the in the center of
the console and rather than having it be
green most of the time plus there were
some nice homey touches because I think
my other thing about the the initial
version of this we got with Smith's is
it felt very unlived in it felt very
sterile it felt too much like a machine
whereas Capaldi's are brought in a few
nice little touches the chalkboards the
bookshelves so that's not just a you
know a gantry up there anymore they did
it's a living space there's stuff up
there for him to go up and mess with and
there's a bust of Beethoven because why
not and that just gave it that slightly
more lived-in slightly quirky er field
that just really
for me and especially in considering you
know where Capaldi's doctor would end up
and you know by series 10 being a
professor it had that kind of professors
office feel to it and I like that as a
vibe and I really like this interior
number three day of the doctor I like to
call this return of the round things so
this is basically just the choral
interior you know it's got that console
from nine and tens era but the wall
swapped out for the old style round
things and honestly I really like it I
like the stark white on the walls versus
the more organic look of the of the
console and everything else because
that's got the more sort of
techno-organic kind of you know earth
tones and then there's the stark white
of the walls I like that contrast it
also makes it quite bright which you
know I've mentioned how modern era
TARDIS has a tendency to be a little bit
over dark at times but this one
absolutely not the case there because of
how bright those walls are I think it's
a wonderful marriage of the classic and
the modern era and it's something that I
kind of wish we could have had for a
little bit longer but for the 50th
anniversary yeah that was a fitting
place to put it
we are getting right up there only a
couple of left to go and number two the
eighth doctor's interior so this would
be from the made-for-tv movie and this
this is just if you asked me to design
my own interior for a TARDIS this is
probably what I would want it to be
feeling more like a library than
anything like an old-fashioned classic
centuries-old library
spiral staircase bookshelves clocks
potted plants a gramophone and just
feeling like you're in somebody's home
with this massive piece of technology
with the console right in the middle of
it I really enjoy it it is like a touch
over dark in there but it's not too too
bad and what's in there is interesting
and varied enough that they like my eyes
never stopped moving around there
because they're all
we settling on something fun and
interesting to look at but even though
this is probably how I would design my
own TARDIS interior still doesn't get my
number one because the number one is the
TARDIS interior that I never would have
thought to have asked for but I love it
so much and that is the fifth doctor's
initial design which I'll just call the
whimsy TARDIS I know that part of the
reason Moffat said they redesigned it
for the more mechanical look that I
didn't like nearly as much is that he
said this felt too much like it was
magic like it was nonsensical and but
that's why I love it I love that there's
these all these things that don't seem
to make any sense and he's got like just
a normal rotary telephone handle and all
these bits that you recognise really
like how the heck is that part of this
thing but there they are and I love this
the slight asymmetry to it it doesn't
feel as controlled which i think is also
very fitting for Smith's doctor who
feels a little bit scattered at times
and it really suits him it's also one of
the better actually probably the
consistently the best lit TARDIS
interior of the modern era which like I
said that's but a nitpick for me
elsewhere but I love it here
I love the warm colours but it never
feels as uniformly toned as some of the
other interiors have at least it never
did for me I love the look of it the
feel of it it's weird it's whimsical
doesn't quite make sense and yet at the
same time feels absolutely perfect and
that is why for me the eleventh Doctor's
first interior is the best that doctor
who has to offer but how do you rank the
pretty sure it's differently than me at
often good it often goes that way but
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff to do
buttons links I mentioned the patreon I
got there's merch there's my peel box so
Media it's all down there click on it
see where it takes you
or don't you don't have to focus at the
end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]